venga vamos a hacer otro ejemplo en este
ejemplo vamos a girar esta función
alrededor de una línea vertical que en
este caso no es el eje de las veces
vamos a rotar la función y es igual a
equis cuadrada menos 1 alrededor de la
recta vertical x igual a menos 2 y bueno
si lo hacemos el sólido de revolución
que me queda es este tazón que tengo
aquí y ya he dibujado y lo que voy a
buscar en esta ocasión es el volumen de
este sólido de revolución usando el
método de los discos así que vamos a
construir un disco y este disco que
tengo aquí tiene un cierto grosor este
grosor es dj en esta ocasión y también
tiene el área de una base o el área de
la cara recuerden que es como una moneda
y lo que voy a querer es que esta área
sea una función de y que para cualquier
y ello pueda tener una cierta área y por
lo tanto ya que saquemos el área
entonces el volumen de este disco va a
ser igual al área que es una función del
porte y es decir por el grosor y después
lo que vamos a tener que hacer es
integrar sobre el intervalo que en este
caso vamos a tomarlo desde desde ya
igual a menos 1 es decir donde corta el
gel así es
hasta vamos a suponer que igual a 3
desde menos uno hasta menos tres esos
van a ser mis límites de integración por
lo tanto esta integral que ya tenemos
aquí y que sabemos que tiene que ser una
integral en base a y va a tener los
límites de integración desde ya igual a
menos 1 hasta ella igual a 3 y esto va a
ser el volumen del sólido de revolución
que yo quiero encontrar y fíjate que
toda esta integral está en términos de
bien por lo tanto lo que me va a hacer
falta para resolver esta integral es
saber cómo encuentro en la función del
área que depende de ella y bueno lo que
sí sabemos es que el área que es una
función de y como es el área de una
circunferencia va a ser pi por el radio
al cuadrado ahora entonces lo que basta
saber es cuál es el radio que dependa de
jane entonces tras lo que vamos es cuál
es el radio cuál es el radio es lo que
queremos y bueno este radio que tenemos
aquí empieza si te das cuenta en la
función que es igual a equis cuadrada
menos uno que por cierto de una vez
vamos a escribirlo como una función de y
por lo tanto si yo sumo uno de los dos
lados le queda que x cuadrada es igual
de uno y si ahora paso el cuadrado del
otro lado me queda que x es igual a la
raíz
1 o dicho de otra manera la función que
depende de que es igual a la raíz
cuadrada de yemas 1x o la función que
depende de ella es lo mismo que la raíz
cuadrada de yemas 1x es igual a la raíz
de yemas 1 y bueno aquí empiece mi radio
pero acaba hasta la recta x igual a
menos 2 yo lo que quiero es la distancia
entre mi fe y mi recta x igual a menos 2
así que lo que quiero que te des cuenta
es que cuando yo hablo de la función de
igual la raíz cuadrada de ye más uno
estoy tomando solamente la primer parte
está que estoy dibujando hasta aquí pero
ahora lo que necesitamos también pues es
sumarle toda la otra distancia y cuánto
es toda la otra distancia pues es desde
x igual a cero hasta x igual a menos 2
es decir 2 unidades de distancia por lo
tanto tu radio total que es una función
de quién va a ser pues claro va a ser la
raíz de ye más uno ya esto hay que
agregarle pues la distancia del 0 al
menos 2 que son dos unidades otra forma
de verlo como lo habíamos hecho en los
vídeos pasados es agarrarte la función
de i
a la función raíz de yemas 1 ya esto
restarle la recta que teníamos pero la
recta que tenemos es x igual a menos 2
por lo tanto me va a quedar la raíz de
yemas 1 - menos 2 es decir más 2 y
espero que todo esto te sea muy
intuitivo
este valor que estoy dibujando aquí esté
con un nuevo color es mi función de y es
mi valor de la función de llama
es decir es el valor de x que obtenemos
cuando nosotros evaluamos allí en esta
función de ella pero si queremos el
radio completo además de esto hay que
agregarle dos unidades de distancia para
que podamos llegar así al centro de
rotación al eje que era el centro de
rotación y hemos pasado la parte más
difícil del problema que era escribir el
radio como una función de james porque
ya teniendo el radio como una función de
ley por lo tanto pues ya tenemos el área
como una función de james es decir pi
por el radio que es una función de ley
que ya la tenemos aquí la raíz de yemas
1 y todo esto agregado más 2 elevado al
cuadrado y lo mejor de todo esto es que
ya tengo entonces el volumen de mis
sólidos de revolución es la integral
desde menos 1 a 3 desde
al menos uno hasta tres y voy a sacar
primero el pib porque es una constante y
adentro me queda pues el área que es una
función de jeff pero esta área ya la
tenemos es la raíz de yemas 12 elevado
al cuadrado es decir el radio elevado al
cuadrado y esto multiplicado por 10 y
bueno por lo tanto nos falta resolver
esta integral y evaluarla lo cual lo
vamos a hacer en el siguiente vídeo pero
además te encargo que antes de ver el
vídeo tú lo intentes portixol